la grande marche pour l'europe
yvelinoise lancée avec une visite de la
maison jean monnet la ministre chargé
des affaires européennes a pu découvrir
la résidence d'un père fondateur de
l'union européenne son salon sa chambre
ou encore des documents officiels
prémices de la création communautaire
mme voyer la méthode monnet rien est
impossible rien on ne s'interdit aucune
idée quand on est face à un péril
en un an on est passé d'un texte à un
traité ce qui est très frappant ses
devoirs quand on parle avec les
responsables de la maison jean monnet
que jean monnet travailler en
rencontrant des gens de toutes
catégories socioprofessionnelles de
toutes origines
en les écoutant pour construire ces
projets c'est exactement la même
démarche que la grande marche pour
l'europe
plusieurs militants de la république en
marche ont échangé avec la ministre des
discussions sur les compétences
européennes les défis climatiques et
migratoires ou encore la révolution
numérique
des questions qui devraient revenir
durant la grande marche le point de
départ pour élaborer le projet européen
des élections en 2019 par exemple n'ont
pas l'éclat ministe de lycées
professionnels qui ont été rendues
possibles grâce au soutien de l'union
européenne ue s'est montré qu'elle est
dans notre quotidien mais juste sur des
aspects de réglementation parce que
c'est souvent comme ça qu'elle est un
peu caricaturé mais elle est là aussi
pour nous protéger et pour nous faire
grandir ce qu'on souhaite vraiment tirer
c'est d'avoir des réponses concrètes aux
problématiques quotidiennes qui se
posent aux yvelinois et aux yvelinoise
parce que nous pensons que sur des
thématiques comme l'économie comme
l'environnement comme la sécurité
l'europe détient une part de solutions
les marcheurs vont faire du porte à
porte dans plus de 90 communes des
yvelines
une campagne prévue sur cinq semaines